We tested that the database
was created successfully.
But now we should test
that reading from and
writing to the sunshine
database works as expected.
I'll show you how we insert a row
of data into the database, and
then query the database
to read it back out.
First, we get a reference to
the database from our SQLI Open Helper.
Which is an instance of
an SQLI database object.
We use this in test create DB.
Since we're writing to the database,
as well as reading,
we're going to get a writable database.
If we were only reading,
then we should use a readable database.
To represent the row of data,
we want to insert into the database,
we use a content values object.
We create one of these,
in the create North pole
location values utility function.
Content values,
contain a set of key value pairs.
You put a key string associated with
the value, into the content value set.
The key string is contain the names
of columns in your database.
The value can contain many
different data types.
Content values,
are used to write databases in Android.
Once we've created our content values.
We call database.insert,
with the table name and content values
to actually create the new row of data.
The return value,
from our insertion is a long,
that contains the new row
ID from the _ID column.
If there's an error inserting,
the return value is negative 1.
Now that we have a row ID,
we can query the database for that row.
There are several query methods that
take in different numbers of parameters.
A query method,
is just a helper function to make it
easier to construct and
execute a select statement.
Let's show how the query
function constructs a statement.
Here's what the base, SQLiteDatabase
query function looks like.
The most basic query we can make
with this only has a table name.
And it returns all columns and
all records.
The rest of the parameters,
would modifying filter
the output of this query.
Adding a projection,
in array of columns, we wish to return,
changes what we are selecting
in select statement below.
The selection parameter
filters the results.
One can optionally also use
the selection arguments to replace any
question marks in the query.
Android creates these
as bound parameters,
in a low level interface to SQLite,
which means, we don't have to worry
about things like escaping
the strings to keep the query valid.
We can also change
the selection arguments,
after our query has been made this way.
The last parameter, as you would expect,
affects the order by cause of our query,
causing it to sort our result
in descending order by date.
The query functions all
return a database cursor.
A cursor object, is a control structure,
that enables traversal over the rows and
columns of our query results set.
Typically, we'll start traversing
results set by calling cursor.move
to first, which will return false if
there were no rows in the result,
which means nothing matched
the query parameters.
We can then call move to next,
iterate through each row.
Once the cursor points to a valid row,
one can call get
column index to return the index of each
database column within the results set.
You can save these values and
use them for every row in the result.
And then you can call get or methods,
that retrieve the values from
that row based upon column index.
Everything we've covered so
far, is how we read and
write from the database in our app.
In tests and in our app code.
For our unit test, though,
we add a step to validate the values
from the cursor with the ones we
originally created the contentValues
object with, by using assert statements.
And, when we're finished we
should close our cursor and
database to release the system
resources as soon as possible